et c'était le rejeté le chichewa c'est
ça mais c'est vrai j'ai toujours
beaucoup d'affection d'ailleurs si
jamais vraiment perdu de vue en vain en
finale est venu me voir quand j'ai joué
au théâtre dans sa région ce avait
invité avec son ami quand on s'appelle
on se doit après on voit on voit là il y
avait quelques jours j'ai eu des mots
pour loana je fais brasse évidemment
lembras évidemment et je fais part de ma
tristesse à delphine et j'explique que
je m'en veut peut-être un peu que j'ai
peut-être été un peu dur et elle me dit
mais non mais en fait j'étais les mots
sur loana j'aime vraiment l'expliquer
c'est que je suis un homme blessé
ouais quand on tente trois fois sa main
à quelqu'un et que cette personne vous
répond pas et qu'on la voit s'enfoncer
s'enfoncer moi quand j'aime quelqu'un je
fais tout pour l'aider quand cette
personne elle est complètement
hermétique et qu'on la voit descendre
comme ça de ne plus en plus de plus en
plus bas moi ça me fend le coeur on a
tous été peiné et delphine la lui a
proposé de l'aider juillet piste offre
aussi tout le monde parce que les gens
se retournent vers l'omd des ans mais
vous faites rien pour l'aider
c'est faux sauf que moi quand je propose
de lège qu'il ne propose pas de l'être
devant les caméras je vous pose de
l'aide face à mon téléphone et et face à
elle mersen a un gros poids de sapin
qu'on a et on s'était mobilisée mais
apparemment vous n'avez qu'à jamais de
réponse on a dit alors il ya quelques
jours j'ai eu des mots un peu un peu
violent mais parce que je suis quelqu'un
de vous blesser elle m'a blessé mais je
voulais prison elle ne m'aime pas c'est
ça le truc c'est ça veut dire qu'elle a
aucune estime pour moi et là j'étais
vraiment blessé voilà l'investît vie je
pense que c'est pas ça elle n'est pas en
calaisis pas laisser elle n'est pas en
capacité de pouvoir avoir un
comportement normal est de pouvoir
donner une réponse à l'un d'entre nous
donc c'est difficile ça fait beaucoup de
peine bien entendu mais je pense qu'elle
est sur un autre tempo et que
malheureusement elle est complètement en
décalage par rapport à la normalité
tu passes août à le faire l'accord et tu
sais très bien à quel point je défends
loana parce que je vais me friter avec
motifs de fond du voile à mes 40 ans
quelqu'un va un peu à contre-courant je
suis agressive parce que je veux la
protéger mais je pense que ça fait quand
même mine de rien 20 ans qu'elle ne
répond pas
qu'elle est présente dans certains
moments mais ça fait 20 ans qu'elle ne
partage pas qu'elle ne répond pas et la
première chose je vais vous dire ce que
c'est
on devait partir tous ensemble au maroc
je crois que c'était pour aller faire
des photos c'était pour gala où je ne
sais plus et on s'est retrouvé à
disneyland parce que loana est pas venir
un rap l'est pas on est tous prix des
passerelles et caetera et au dernier
moment de pim à ce parce que non mais je
pense qu'elle est donc saviez vous par
exemple les mots les plus durs sur elle
sur le oui
whatsapp c'est vrai mais parce que moi
j'ai des gens dans mon entourage qui
sont morts de ses dépendances qui sont
morts de toutes ces maladies de
dépendance et que loana le seul truc
qu'il faut que les gens comprennent ce
qu'on arrête de trouver toujours des
boucs émissaires qui c'est de la faute
d'untel quand on regarde les émissions
de télé où on passe son temps à l'invité
c'est pour moi pas lui rendre service
parce que souvent on dit jean edouard a
des mots durs contre loana non c'est que
souvent ils sont déformés et moi je suis
une proie facile pour dire du mal
comment ce soit c'est al assad à lui
faire fait de maintenant mais le mot le
ski fogelman chose mais non mais c'est
pas un mot d'amour c'est que moi modeste
dans ce genre de problème on ne cherche
pas les causes d'abord on règle le
problème
on cherche les causes après y'a pas de
bouc émissaire il faut se soigner et se
soigner dans ce genre de problème c'est
pas 15 jours c'est pas trois semaines
ces bandes alors la télé et ceux qui
l'invitent en télé qui pense lui rendre
service
j'en doute grandement pour faire du buzz
non c'est pas lui rendre service parce
que elle elle pense que ça va lui sauver
sa vie d'aller à la télé c'est ce qui va
la tuer aujourd'hui il faut qu'elle
parte un don se reposait définitivement
sa saison value hang on va lui souhaiter
de se reposer et d'aller mieux
mais c'était important c'était important
d'avoir c'est vrai parce qu'on a
beaucoup dit c'est personne n'a rien
fait pour elle mais quand je vous
entends fouet ses poils assez tôt à vie
devant nous on ne fait pas de face aux
caméras s'est fait voir et bravo bravo
bravo steevy